30 minute workouts
20 minute recipes 10 minute mindfulness
ready to become
[Music]
get feel on the app store or google play
hi everyone welcome back to another
total body strength training workout
today's workout is going to be a super
set that means we will be doing two
exercises back to back with minimal rest
in between and we will end with a short
cardio blaster for each round so what
you'll need is a pair of medium weight
dumbbells let's start lifting and let's
get stronger together
[Music]
let's start with a quick warm-up today's
exercises is all about slow and
controlled movement okay so let's start
with nice and easy squat to warm our
lower body up
good so remember push your butt back
drive your butt down and push up with
your heels nice and easy just warming up
the muscles okay relax your upper body
just swing your arms forward and back
good so each circuit we will be
alternating between lower body and upper
body and we will be working on all the
major muscles in our body
good give me a few more
last two more done and up nice and easy
and now let's get in some side lunges
step out
step back in
and step out okay so push your butt back
straighten your right leg
and alternate
good
back
feel the squeeze on your outer glutes
raise your core look straight ahead push
and back up
good feel the stretch on your inner
thighs
as well
and up
good job two more on each side
remember nice and controlled movement so
no
bounces all right
and good all right a little bit of warm
up for the upper body step at the edge
of your mat let's get into an inchworm
to
a
push-up
and a downward facing dog all right
slowly inch
back and come back up
stretch up inch worm
if you need to you can bend your knees
slightly
one full push up
or knee push up
and come back
up good job three more
if you want to get onto your knee knee
push up
slowly come back up
push your butt back
and stretch up last one more
slowly inch all the way forward give me
one strong push up
and slowly inch back
and stretch
your body
all right okay just shake it out a
little bit
twist side to side all right
the first circuit is going to be a lower
body circuit so what i'm going to do is
grab your dumbbells between four to five
kilos each okay the first workout is
going to be goblet squat so place both
dumbbells directly in front of you if
you want you can also grab one heavier
dumbbell okay so again stand shoulder
width apart with your toes pointer
forward place both dumbbells directly in
front of you and i want you to push your
butt back
squat up
and lower yourself down okay
so remember keep your chest up you
should feel that extra tension
by lifting the weights this is going to
challenge you more
nice and easy nice and controlled
movement
slow three counts down
one count up squeeze your glutes right
at the top okay
down
up squeeze
down
up and squeeze
good job we're working on our glutes our
hamstrings as well as
our
quads and up okay
the second exercise is going to be a
cutsy lunge okay so grab both dumbbells
just next to you
what i'm going to do is start with your
left leg back cross over
lunge down
up
tap
cross and down okay if you want to add
more challenge
try to keep your knees bent throughout
the workout so do not straighten your
leg keep that constant tension in your
thighs down
up
place your feet onto the ground down and
up
okay go as low as you can push up
remember to look straight ahead
we're working on our outer
glutes
down and up good back
and up good job nice and controlled
movement
a few more
down up
keep a chest up
back
and up all right quick 20 seconds rest
back to the first workout goblet squat
okay
weight directly in front of you stand
shoulder width apart i'm going to stand
slightly to the side remember to push
your butt back
squeeze your glutes right at the top
catch your breath and let's go down
and
up okay
go as low as you can
and push up
good job
breathe out as you come up
breathe in
as you lower your body down
look straight ahead
strong legs
strong arms
down
breathe out good job
keep going
squat deeper
squat
lower
good last few more down
up
and drop it down okay
curtsy lunge all right
final workout and a short cardio blaster
ready drive your left leg across to the
back so remember cross
with your right foot pointed forward
down and up
okay let's do it
cross
down and up
tap
and up
keep a slight bend in your knees
throughout the workout
stay low okay that's going to add
that extra challenge
down and up
cross
and up good
see my knees are constantly
bent
down and up
a little bit tension
good job
a few more
cross over
remember to keep your chest up
do not lean your body forward
and good
drop the weights down
whoa
short break
30 seconds of cardio blaster okay it's
going to be squat jump let's really
challenge our legs only 30 seconds and
you will get a short break
right after this let's go down
up
remember to land
gently
push up with
your heels
squat low
push it up
this is
the burn the burning part
let's go
through the burn in your thighs
push up
down last five more seconds
remember to keep breathing that's two
more give me one more
and
short break
oh my gosh okay
short break
give your leg a rest we want to move
into our upper body okay so
the next two workouts will be working on
our shoulders as well as our biceps okay
so again
one way to always make sure is that
you're standing tall
and that your your back is flat stand in
a neutral position remember there
shouldn't be any momentum coming from
your body so the first workout is a
hammer curl to a shoulder press so again
nice and controlled hammer curl
shoulder press
no momentum do not do this
if you're doing this you're lifting too
heavy okay hammer curl
press straight up
nice and controlled
curl up
press good job
and down
keep your elbows pointed back
keep it close to your body curl up press
it straight up
down
and release okay again
release slowly very good job 20 seconds
break the next workout is going to be an
l race okay so we're working on our side
and front down so this is how it's going
to be
side and front
alternate okay
remember to keep your arms straight with
a slight bend in your elbows again
remember do not use momentum
up
hold it control
up
control and down
alternating between the right and the
left
up
and back down
good job
it is tough but we're strong
showed us our smaller muscle group okay
so it will be more challenging up
down
up
and down
nice and controlled
forward and to the side and shake it out
okay shoulder rolls
we're repeating the first workout again
hammer curl to shoulder press all right
shake it out a little bit remember to
keep your elbows close to your body do
not flare them out right close to your
body
stand firm let's go curl it up
push you straight up down
curl work on your bicep work on your
shoulders
and release
curl good
strong arms good job and release
up
push it up
do not hold your breath as you curl okay
remember to pace your breathing
as you curl
and breathe in
as you lower the dumbbells down up
press it up
down and back
good job
last one more
let's go one
up
and
down okay
l raises okay
so working on the side and the front
down
if you need to you can drop the
dumbbells for a little while and grab it
okay
let's go five seconds left ready
final shoulder blaster okay let's go
up
down
up
and down keep the dumbbell in line with
your
face okay not too high up just at eye
level
up and down remember to keep a slight
bend in your elbows up
and down done
good job
keep going
we have 10 more seconds
oh you will find that
one side is usually stronger than the
other side
up
and down okay
good news drop the dumbbells okay 30
seconds of cardio blaster this time we
want to work on our upper bodies that
means
punches okay jump and cross jump and
cross i want you to make sure that
you're twisting and rotating your hips
and the power should be coming from your
hips ready let's go straight arms for
those of you who have done my kickboxing
workout videos you will know that this
is one of my favorite cardio moves okay
remember that
your punches should be in line
with
your eye
level straight twist rotate
rotate
power from your hips keep twisting last
few more strong punches
one more
and take a short break okay if you need
to grab some water drink some water we
want to rest our upper body and move
back into our lower body okay so
grab your weights
lie onto the mat
let's start with glued bridge okay this
is a really good workout to focus on
your glutes what i'm going to do is
place both dumbbells just around your
hips and place your heels close to your
butt and squeeze your glutes as you come
up
and back down
remember this is a slow and controlled
movement but what i want to do is
squeeze and hold for two counts right at
the top really feel the engagement on
your glutes and lower back down if you
have a heavier pair of dumbbells you can
use that as well okay squeeze
drive your hips up
squeeze it hold it back down
up
and down good job
feel it right
at your butt
last two more
one more squeeze
and slowly lower back down okay get back
up let's get into a kneeling position
okay so
place your
knees slightly wider than shoulder width
apart what i want to do is place both
dumbbells just on your shoulders we're
going to work on kneeling hip thruster
okay so lower your butt down as you come
up
squeeze all right remember
thrust forward and squeeze
down and squeeze
so your upper body should be relaxed
squeeze all right still working on your
glutes good job again if you have a
heavy pair of dumbbells you can use that
squeeze push your hips forward thrust
your hips forward
squeeze good remember to hold for one
count
squeeze
back down
up
keep your back flat do not hunch forward
and squeeze
good job well done now let's get back
down onto the mat let's work on glued
bridge okay
again place the dumbbells just right on
your hips
heels slightly close to your butt okay
and remember to drive
up
and squeeze for one count back down
don't touch the floor up
back down
up
good job
up squeeze it
and
good
slowly lower down and up
three counts one two three
and push it up
remember to keep your knees
shoulder width apart
okay up
squeeze it
i can feel my butt on fire just few more
up
and slowly lower back down get back up
all right kneeling hip thruster okay if
you want to get a heavier pair of
dumbbells you can
because your glute is a big muscle group
all right place both dumbbells just on
your shoulders
kneel down remember
sit back down okay sit back down as you
come up thrust
back down
and thrust forward
okay good job
do not rest at the bottom it's just a
gentle tap
and thrust
very good
last few more
and guess what we're ending with a short
30 seconds
cardio blaster my favorite part to
really bring the heat up
thrust
nice
up
and down
up
and back down
and drop the weights okay
for your cardio blaster it's going to be
in and out squat okay still working on
our glutes working on the power of our
lower body as well so start white
what i want to do is tap the floor okay
tap the floor in
tap the floor okay
in
good job tap go low squat low
tap and reach for your mat
tap step wide point your toes out
good
last 15 seconds
strong leg
tap
remember it's not hunching forward it's
driving your butt
down
a few more
that's one more
and rest
30 seconds break
good news
rest your lower body it's back up to our
upper body okay
okay the first workout is going to be a
push-up with shoulder tabs
all right so
choose your option you can either do a
full push-up or a push-up on your knees
so i'm going to start with the easier
version all right
so
get onto your knees
start with a push-up
tap left and right tap
and back down remember minimal
rotation on your hips
up
tap
back down
and tap okay
if you find that this is too easy and
you want a little bit more challenge
then get onto your toes
full push up
shoulder tap
tap
the goal is do not
dip your hips side to side
tap and tap
strong chest strong
shoulders
and tap okay
right
still working on our chest muscles okay
the next workout is going to be a bridge
pull over so
lie down on the mat
grab both dumbbells keep them together
get into a bridge position
stay in this position lower the
dumbbells behind your head pull it up
and squeeze your chest okay so lower it
down keep a slight bend in your elbows
pull and squeeze
your
chest
so the dumbbells should be at your chest
level good job
control movement don't rush the workout
keep it strong squeeze your glutes up
and squeeze good job
feel the work on your chest and you
should also feel a slight pull on your
back muscles extend and pull remember to
keep a slight bend in your elbows up all
right now
drop the weights
back into push-ups with shoulder taps so
choose your option okay either a full
push-up or a knee push-up
whatever you decide on progress from
there
are we ready final 40 seconds of
push-ups let's go push up
tap left and right
down
and tap
raise your car
flat back
keep your body in one
straight
line
tap
down and up
down and up
keep going you're almost there give me
two more push-ups okay
that's one more
come on let's go
tap and tap
all right
reach pull over
if you're new to this movement
take it slow okay
take it easy
it's more important that you feel the
work on your chest and also a little bit
on your back so dumbbells straight up
heels close to your butt bridge position
drop it lower it down do not just drop
it control it and squeeze
nice and
controlled
up and squeeze
good job remember do not dip your hips
okay squeeze your glutes i know it's a
lot of things happening
in one movement but stay with me
engage every muscle
lower back down
up
back down
and
up
good job
strong chest ladies
and
up okay
let's just drop the dumbbells all right
cardio blaster 30 seconds okay lateral
shoot through
just like a break dancer okay so start
on all fours
all right
lift your knees off the mat
shoot your left leg through
and alternate okay so release
your left leg and your right hand
and change
push it up and get your core
get back onto all fours and push
through kick through
good job
let's keep going
push
nice
twist your body
face your chest up
a few more
and well done
oh my gosh that was a tougher circuit
wasn't it
take a short break
next second we want to still focus on
our upper body but on our back muscles
alright take a short break
next workout is going to be more
challenging it will require more
stability on your wrist as well
renegade roll okay so
start in a high plank position but hold
on to your dumbbells feet wider pull the
dumbbell close to your belly with your
elbows pointed back
and
roll
good job just like a single arm row but
you're in a high plank position so this
is going to challenge
your core muscles your balance
and also to work on the strength
of your back
and your arms if this is too difficult
what you can do is place one pump on the
floor roll
place it down
and roll
okay
eventually work on your wrist stability
roll and back down
all right
next workout
just place the dumbbells in front of you
you won't need the dumbbells okay
it is a challenging workout
superman squeeze
it's going to work on your back muscles
and also your traps alright so
let's just focus on our upper body okay
so raise up
pull squeeze your back squeeze your legs
release and drop back down
up
squeeze
release and drop back down if you want
to you can raise your legs up
squeeze your glutes squeeze it back and
release
up
squeeze okay
and down remember at the end of each
movement hold it for one to two counts
before you release
up
squeeze
down
and release
and just gaze
onto the floor
squeeze
down and release
okay push yourself up all right guess
what we're repeating the entire circuit
once more so grab your dumbbells choose
your option
we're starting with renegade row again
okay so get into a high plank position
spread your feet slightly wider
row
back down
roll
and down
nice and controlled movement roll
good remember to point your elbows
back it's not going to the side it's
going back
and pull the dumbbells close to your
waistline
good job
shoulders in line with your palms i know
this is challenging but stay with me
you're almost there
that's a few more
give me two more
squeeze it squeeze last one more
and slowly
lower back down okay
place the dumbbell to the side
squeeze okay so lie flat
onto your belly
ah
i'm trying hard to catch my breath i'm
feeling strong let's finish this circuit
strong up
squeeze
and release
up
squeeze
and release
okay
let's keep going
squeeze your glutes squeeze your back
and release okay if you want to
challenge yourself you can grab hold of
a really light pair of dumbbells either
one
or
two kilos up
squeeze
back down
keep going
you got this
that's one more and
slowly come back up okay let's get back
up
cardio blaster all right okay
this cardio blaster is going to work on
your balance as well skaters all right
so what i'm going to do is hop to the
side
hop
and try to reach down all right only 30
seconds
find your rhythm find your balance
try to reach and cross your left leg
over and your right leg across
keep going
reach
and reach
good job
strong
total body strength
workout
last few more wider steps let's go let's
pass it off
and
rest it out all right
take a short break good news you have
one finest circuit and the focus will be
on your core alright so for this circuit
you can do it without any weights or you
can grab one
dumbbell okay so lie flat onto the floor
the first workout is going to be full
crunches okay so start with the dumbbell
up
what i'm going to do is extend
and
crunch it up
extend
and crunch okay so extend your legs as
straight as possible
without
over arching your lower back
okay only lower your legs down without
overarching your lower back remember the
focus is on your abs
if you're feeling the pain
on your lower back
then try to keep both
legs
higher up okay
or just keep it in a 90 degree position
and just
crunch all right this is your option
okay good job all right now
drop the dumbbell
next workout is going to be plank arm
raise oh
final circuit let's do this strong let's
get into a high plank
simple movement i want you to reach
forward
reach
and reach forward okay
simple movement
but the goal here is to brace your core
do not dip your hip to the left or to
the right
keep both
arms
in line with your shoulders
and you can spread your fingers apart
for more balance
reach and reach remember to gaze onto
your mat okay do not
arch
or strain your neck look down
look at one focal point
raise your core
and
raise
your arm
good let's feel more
and drop it down okay
we're repeating the entire second again
grab your dumbbell or do without your
dumbbell
full crunches all right so choose your
option
you can start by keeping your legs in a
90 degree position okay start here
and eventually
as you progress
extend
your legs
out okay extend it out and crunch up
the goal is to lift your shoulders
off
the mat
all right extend
crunch up
and bring your knees
close to your chest
extend and crunch
nice and controlled movement again do
not drop your legs
we're working on our upper abs and our
lower abs as well
all right oh my gosh
drop the dumbbell
get up
plank um
raise okay
right let's get into a high plank
oh my hair is a mess and that's how you
know you have done a good workout okay
all right high plank let's go left
right
left
and right for more challenge keep your
feet close together
this will engage your core even more
you will need to work harder to keep
your
balance okay
left and right left and right
good job keep going
breathe
last final core workout and one more 30
seconds of cardio blaster and you are
done
stay with me
one more
and drop okay
guess what 30 seconds of cardio blaster
all right it's going to be your favorite
mountain climber okay
keeping my hair tight
and let's end this strong together okay
high plank position drive your knees in
towards your chest okay let's go only
30 seconds
choose your speed you can start off slow
or if you really want to end strong then
blast off and speed it up okay drive
your knees in
feel your heart rate pumping do your
co-working
feel the
strain on your arms keep going
that's a few more push into the ground
three
two
one
oh my
gosh
all right guys
well done slowly get back up
and just
take this time to catch your breath okay
we have done an amazing job that was a
solid
30 minute of total body strength
training so now let's take this time to
just cool our body down okay
do not rush to go anywhere it's just a
quick two to three minutes of cool down
all right so what i'm going to do is
just
get down onto your mat
let's do a little bit of stretching for
your legs and your hip flexor so
drive your left leg forward
just like a lunge position but i want
you to push
your hips forward and feel the stretch
on your right hip flexor okay
and just slowly raise both arms up
and stand tall
and just catch your breath just bring
your heart rate back down you have done
an amazing job
just slowly
bring your heart rate back down and now
just twist
and look as far back as you can
okay open up your chest
feel the stretch on your back
and
now slowly straighten your left leg
and i want you to feel the stretch on
your hamstrings all right we did lots of
lower body workout lots of explosive
movements so let's just stretch it out
stretch and feel the stretch on your
hamstrings
good and just hold it here
and now bring it back
change the other side okay so right leg
forward remember
drop your hips forward
feel the stretch on your left hip flexor
okay
and now raise both arms straight up
and just breathe
all right
slowly
go deeper into your
stretch and now twist loop the opposite
side
flat back
and slowly straighten your right leg
and feel the stretch on your right
hamstring okay i have tight
right hamstrings so
try to lower your body as much as you
can and feel the pull on your hamstrings
and remember to go deeper in your
stretch you have to just keep breathing
out and just relax do not hold your
breath okay breathe out relax
and just pace your breathing do not hold
your breath that's not gonna help you're
just gonna feel more pain
and now slowly come back up
let's just
do a few shoulder rolls
okay
and back
and now i want to slowly stand
up okay let's just take three deep
breaths
really release
all the tension in your body you've done
a great job ready breathe in
stretch up
and
that's two more breathe in
stretch up
last one more okay let's side out really
loud together breathe in catch as much
breath as you can breathe in
hold it
ready loud side
well done guys that was a total body
strength training workout okay if you
want to challenge yourself keep
progressing by lifting heavier don't
forget to also check out other full body
workout videos on my youtube channel as
well as healthy recipes and if you
haven't yet subscribed then hit the
subscribe button and i will see you in
my next workout session
all the best and stay strong